one of Kennedy's genius boys came up
with the because Kennedy's
administration was run by a lot of
Harvard graduates and Ivy League
graduates and so you know they were
supposed to be pretty intelligent but
intelligence and wisdom are not the same
thing but anyways they established a
policy which was called mutual assured
destruction which means if you hit me I
kill you and then you kill me and so
it'd be better if we just didn't bother
and the acronym was mad right mutual
assured destruction it's like you know
just thinking about that it's a chilling
thought it's like what horrible entity
thought that up as a joke you know you
think well is that some says that some
politicians idea of whiffed like where'd
that come from so that's a hell of a
thing to make a joke about you know mad
well that was right it was definitely
mad you know and the odd thing is is
that we didn't blow ourselves up and we
didn't have a third world war and you
know you you can't make a solid claim
that the event ssin of nuclear weapons
was necessarily the worst thing that
could have happened you know because
even the Soviets who were completely
insane and of course the Maoists are
probably even worse they weren't insane
enough to start a nuclear war now Stalin
there's evidence there's debate about it
but there was F there's evidence that
Stalin was basically murdered partly by
Khrushchev was who was his who was his
successor when Stalin died Khrushchev
and three other people were in his house
and what happened in Stalin's house the
night he died is not clear but I read a
book recently called Stalin
interestingly enough that was written by
a guy who had access to the full
Communist Party archives you know which
was relatively new thing and that was
his conclusion and he also believed that
Stalin was gearing up to do it an
invasion of Europe and that he didn't
give a damn how many cities would have
to be bombed in order for the Soviets to
roll through and Stalin he was like that
you know Stalin was perfectly capable of
taking entire Nations of people out in
Eastern Europe by train and shipping
them out to Siberia in the middle of the
winter with nothing to eat and no tools
and letting them live which of course
they didn't and that
women children men you know shorn of all
their belongings and thrust out into the
middle of nowhere to perish or or live
as they saw fit and if they perished so
much the better as far as Stalin was
concerned and so he wasn't exactly the
sort of person the idea of a nuclear war
would necessarily stop and it's
certainly possible that that's what he
was hoping for you know because when we
look at people like Stalin and Hitler we
think well you know they're after world
domination you know and you think well
in some sense that's kind of a positive
motivation right I mean no really but
it's like if you have a Corvette say and
someone steals it you could think well I
know why they stole it did they want to
have the Corvette you know what's it's
an understandable motivation to want
power it's not necessarily an admirable
one although sometimes power is a
perfectly what a reasonable thing to
pursue but I don't have any idea why we
ever assumed that those guys were after
victory like you should never make the
presupposition that everyone is out to
win some people are out to lose and the
more people they can take with them the
better you know and when Hitler died he
committed suicide in a bunker way down
below Berlin while Berlin was on fire in
Europe was burning it's like as far as I
can tell that was exactly what Hitler
was after right from the beginning you
know he was interested in fire as a
purifying agent you know he's a fire
worshipper in some sense because if you
look at the nuremberg gatherings of the
nazis you know they're spectacular
spectacular celebrations unbelievably
dramatic and impressive and they've
frequently featured fire and fires a
purifying agent you know and hitler by
the end of world war ii was he was
pretty contemptuous of the germans
because they really hadn't served him
well and it wasn't like he thought well
maybe it wasn't such a good idea to
start a whole second world war you know
because it was a little on the
narcissistic side we might say but by
the time the russians came marching in
and germany was in ruins
hitler was perfectly happy to have the
Allies Trump all over the citizens
because that's what they deserved
anyways and so that's the sort of guy he
was and so why we would assume that he
wanted to win just because that's what
he said is something I've never been
able to understand you know the kids who
shot up Columbine
want to win I wanted to kill as many
people as possible to make a point and
then they wanted to kill themselves just
in case you didn't exactly get the point
and the point was the more destruction
the better and if I have to go along
with that hey no problem that just makes
me a little bit more serious than I
might have otherwise be and so those
sorts of motivations are not pleasant to
understand but we have enough
documentation about events like that you
know especially the mass killings those
guys have written down exactly why they
do it now I have some excellent books on
extraordinary vengeful mad serial
killers and mass murderers I know
exactly how they think there's a great
book if you're interested in this sort
of thing called panzram PA n z ra m and
carl panzram was a serial killer and
rapist who live pretty much early in the
20th century and he was a tough
delinquent he sort of kid from a large
family and when he was you know 13 14
they sent him off to some reform school
and it was rent run by the same sort of
people that run Canada's residential
schools and you know so those were
basically predators on children and of
course he was raped and and brutalized
and tormented and in all sorts of
horrible ways and but he was a tough guy
and when he came out he decided that you
know the human race really wasn't worth
that much and that he was going to wreak
as much mayhem as he possibly could for
the rest of his life he raped a thousand
men he killed dozens of people he kept
track of the dollar value of the
buildings he burned down like this was a
serious gun and he wasn't he was bent on
destruction and that's that what is what
were his dying words first of all there
was a committee I believe of women who
intervened on behalf of him because they
were anti capital punishment and he said
to them if I remember correctly that he
wished the human race had one neck so
that he could put his hands around it
and squeeze so you know that was his way
of pointing out to the people who didn't
think that maybe capital punishment was
justified in his case that maybe they
weren't thinking clearly and then to the
hangman he said hurry up you who's your
bastard I could kill ten men in the time
it takes you to hang me
so you know you don't get a statement
like that from someone who isn't
thoroughly committed to what he's doing